U.S shoots down Chinese spy balloon who
in the world would have the expertise to
know whether that's legal or not
everyone asks what the Chinese balloon
is doing
but no one asks how the Chinese balloon
is doing well the answer is poorly uh it
was shot down
at last our long National nightmare is
over the Chinese balloon that terrorized
American citizens from Alaska to South
Carolina is no more the United States
can now begin the arduous process of
reconstruction and perhaps
reconciliation
look was the United States legally
allowed to shoot down that Chinese
balloon or not and if so on what legal
basis
that's all we're here for today as a
former artillery officer joint terminal
attack controller and lawyer in the U.S
Marine Corps and current civilian
prosecutor I have the authority and
contractual obligation to opine on the
internet about all things vaguely
military and law
sorry those credentials plus my gigantic
ego for themselves so let's dig in to
balloon gate on January 28th a balloon
originating in the People's Republic of
China entered the American air defense
identification Zone north of the
Aleutian Islands it proceeded to drift
at about 60 000 feet elevation over
Alaska western Canada and then through
the contiguous United States from
northern Idaho to South Carolina once
the balloon had started drifting over
the Atlantic Ocean a U.S Air Force F-22
shot it down in a statement Secretary of
Defense Lloyd Austin who absolutely can
still rep 315 Natty on the bench press
describe the balloon as a high altitude
surveillance balloon which was being
used by the PRC in an attempt to surveil
strategic sites in the continental
United States
President Biden then gave authorization
to take down the balloon as soon as the
mission could be accomplished without
undue risk to American lives under the
balloon's path ultimately the dod
decided to attack that dastardly balloon
over U.S territorial Waters off the
coast of South Carolina
on February 4th about six miles from the
coast a U.S Air Force F-22 engaged the
balloon with an air-to-air missile and
took it down pushing out just slightly
our subjugation by our balloon overlords
U.S Navy and Coast Guard vessels were in
the area to take custody of the remains
China meanwhile expressed strong
discontent and protest against the use
of force to attack an alleged civilian
unmanned aircraft whose presence on U.S
territory was totally accidental the
Chinese foreign Ministry went on to say
in these circumstances for the United
States to insist on using Armed Force is
clearly an excessive reaction that
seriously violates International
Convention China will resolutely defend
the legitimate rights and interests of
the Enterprise involved and retains the
right to respond further now strong
discontent and protest
that's like the Diplomatic equivalent of
giving another country a one-star Yelp
review at the end of that statement is
kind of interesting was this a serious
violation of International Convention
and does that mean it's a violation of
international law and what does that
mean studying international law is a
little bit like studying how
preschoolers play games on the
playground
some game rules are explicit and
probably even written down somewhere
some rules are just kind of understood
and can change a little bit over time
and then there are plenty of situations
where there are no rules and honestly if
you even ask the kids what the rules are
they probably won't consistently explain
them also some of the kids have nukes so
that changes things too in international
law one of the key foundational Concepts
is sovereignty states are sovereign for
most of History States had the absolute
and inviable right to decide what
happens within their own borders
now the 20th century saw some attempts
to limit the concept of sovereignty for
example in like genocide but it is still
a fundamental principle of international
law in fact Article 2 of the U.N Charter
states that the United Nations is based
on the principle of The Sovereign
equality of all its members now
sovereign states have borders those
borders can follow land features like
mountains or Canyons or water features
like rivers and oceans or can just cut
right through a farmer's field based on
an agreement and probably some bloody
wars in the past
whatever makes up the borders states
have complete sovereignty over the
airspace above their territory no
foreign aircraft may fly into a state's
airspace without the permission of that
state which may be granted by either ad
hoc Decisions by the state or by general
or bilateral International agreements so
here's a question what's the Vertical
Limit of airspace I mean it can't go on
forever and the short answer is there is
no International agreement that fixes
the Vertical Limit I mean there have
been some attempts to set it at
something called the Carman line which
sits about 100 kilometers or 62 miles
above mean sea level but there's nothing
definitive there's no one agreement a
really easy quick rule of thumb is this
if it's in orbit it's in space not
airspace for our purposes let's just
agree that the balloon at sixty thousand
feet above mean sea level is well within
the United States's Sovereign airspace
Coastal States like the United States
have some additional airspace as well a
coastal state State can claim water out
to 12 nautical miles from the low tide
line as the state's territorial sea now
there are also things called the
contiguous Zone and the exclusive
economic zone but we just don't need to
talk about it
in the territorial sea a country has
exclusive Sovereign jurisdiction those
Waters belong to the state just as much
as their land and so by extension
Coastal states have complete sovereignty
over the airspace over their territorial
Seas so all well and good so far but how
do we get to the world we actually live
in with people and cargo flying between
sovereign states every day I mean
obviously they're not just violating
each other's Sovereign airspace well
when it comes to relations between
sovereign states the traditional view is
that a state is only Bound by rules it
consents to so the primary source of
international law is the treaty two
sovereign states consent to a treaty
once they consent they are bound
violation of that treaty can come with
consequences according to the U.S
Constitution a duly signed and ratified
treaty has the force of federal law and
before I see it in the comments we don't
have the time to talk about the
difference between self-executing and
non-self-executing treaties we're not
doing that we're also not talking about
customary international law maybe some
other time
preferably never the primary treaty
dealing with air traffic is the
convention on International civil
aviation which went into effect in 1947
and is also known as the Chicago
convention the Chicago convention has
been ratified by every single member
country of the United Nations with the
exception of notorious Rogue State
Liechtenstein
[Music]
that means the US and China are bound to
follow it the Chicago convention goes
into detail about how States should deal
with a number of different situations
involving civil aviation in addition to
establishing the rights and obligations
of member countries the Chicago
convention established an agency within
the U.N called the international civil
aviation organization or ikau ikau
exists to develop and adopt standards
and recommended practices member states
are required to keep their internal
standards and practices as uniform as
possible Article 1 of the Chicago
convention acknowledges what we already
know every state has complete and
exclusive sovereignty over airspace
above its territory article 3 goes on to
say every state must refrain from
resorting to the use of weapons against
civil aircraft in flight now this is
important it is generally understood
that a use of force against a foreign
registered civil aircraft is assimilated
to a use of force against the state of
red registration and therefore a breach
of Article 2 Sub 4 of the UN Charter and
Associated customary international law
let me say that again more simply
shooting down a foreign civil aircraft
can be seen as an act of War thanks
Captain Obvious the Chicago convention
also very helpfully talks about unmanned
free balloons because folks this ain't
the first time a balloon has floated
over a foreign state
Annex 2 to the Chicago convention is
called rules of the air and appendix 4
to Annex 2 specifically talks about the
rules governing unmanned free balloons
now here just to be clear a free balloon
it's not like Free Willy it's just a
balloon that doesn't have any tethers
so here are the pertinent rules
paragraph 2.2 an unmanned free balloon
other than a light balloon used
exclusively for meteorological purposes
and operated in a manner prescribed by
the appropriate Authority shall not be
operated across the territory of another
state without appropriate authorization
from the other state concerned paragraph
2.3
the authorization referred to in 2.2
shall be obtained prior to the launching
of the balloon if there is reasonable
expectation when planning the operation
that the balloon May drift into airspace
over the territory of another state so
now we understand why the Chinese
foreign Ministry phrased their
objections the way they did remember
they said in these circumstances for the
United States to insist on using Armed
Force is clearly an excessive reaction
that seriously violates International
Convention China will resolutely defend
the legitimate rights and interests of
the Enterprise involved and retains the
right to respond further so first the
Chinese statement talks about the
legitimate rights and interests of the
Enterprise involved that's a clue that's
the first indication that they're
relying on the Chicago convention
because it implies that the balloon was
a civil aircraft rather than
governmental or military in nature more
importantly by describing the balloon as
a civil aircraft as I said before
the Chinese foreign Ministry is saying
that the use of force against the
balloon is equivalent to the use of
force against China itself second the
Chinese foreign Ministry claims that the
balloon was just a weather balloon if
that's true per paragraph 2.2 it is an
international standard that you can fly
a light balloon exclusively used for
meteorological purposes over another
country without that other country's
authorization now one problem for the
Chinese is that a light balloon has to
have a payload weighing less than four
kilograms or about 8.8 pounds just
eyeballing that Chinese balloon the
payload looks pretty big and according
to One news source the payload was the
size of two or three school buses so
unless those buses are made out of paper
payload almost certainly weighs more
than four kilos and therefore the
authorization exception in paragraph 2.2
wouldn't apply the other problem for the
Chinese foreign Ministry really boils
down to messaging right before the shoot
down happened a spokesperson
acknowledged that the balloon was
Chinese in origin and described it as a
civilian Airship used for research
mainly meteorological purposes well
that's not the standard for paragraph
2.2 of the Chicago convention the
standard is exclusively for
meteorological purposes not mainly
meteorological purposes
oops third the Chinese foreign Ministry
stated that the balloon was affected by
the westerlies and had limited
self-steering capability so it deviated
far from its planned course now this
statement is designed to deal with
paragraph 2.3 remember that paragraph
says it's an international standard that
you need to obtain authorization for
overflight if there's a reasonable
expectation that the balloon May drift
into the airspace of another country
basically China's saying that there was
no reasonable expectation at the
planning stage that the balloon might
drift into U.S airspace so no U.S
authorization was required this is a
better argument for the Chinese but we
would require a lot more information
about the supposed planned purpose of
the balloon to really evaluate it while
the Chinese government tried to shoehorn
the balloon into the legal framework of
the Chicago convention the U.S
government rejected that approach
entirely by claiming the balloon is
military or intelligence in nature the
U.S is implicitly saying that the
Chicago convention does not apply at all
instead we're operating under the more
fundamental framework of sovereignty the
United States has exclusive sovereignty
over its airspace the U.S has consented
to a certain framework for foreign civil
aircraft to operate within its airspace
but the U.S has never consented and does
not consent to Chinese surveillance
balloons in its airspace but hey didn't
we used to do surveillance missions over
like Russia and they got to do the same
thing with us yes in fact 35 separate
countries in nato in the Warsaw Pact
signed the treaty on open Skies in 1992
which specifically allowed for unarmed
aerial surveillance flights over one
another's territories the problem is you
know one that never included China and
two president Trump withdrew the U.S
from that treaty in 2020. more
importantly that was a treaty the U.S
consented to it the U.S did not consent
to the Chinese surveillance balloon so
is there some special legal basis for
shooting down that balloon
honestly not really I mean insofar as it
was a surveillance balloon and it
violated the US's Sovereign airspace
it was a legitimate Target just as if it
were a fighter jet it is worth pointing
out that the U.S never argued that the
balloon was somehow a threat the
Department of Defense made it clear that
the balloon did not pose a military or
physical threat so this isn't about
self-defense in the law of armed
conflict there's there's no invocation
of article 51 of the UN Charter which
says nothing in the present Charter
shall impair the inherent right of
individual or Collective self-defense if
an armed attack occurs against a member
of the United Nations the US's position
is purely about sovereignty the thing
about sovereignty of course is that
while it is absolutely a thing it is
always balanced by the realities of
domestic and international politics just
because the U.S could shoot down the
balloon doesn't mean it has to shoot
down the balloon and just the same if
China really does feel like this is a
violation of the Chicago convention and
a use of force against China itself
China has the choice of whether to
respond appropriately or just kind of
let it slide that's politics all in all
this is just yet another touchy Affair
between the US and China One That Could
fizzle out entirely or one that could be
another rung on the escalation ladder to
armed conflict
only time will tell
speaking of armed conflict though
Apparently after the balloon was cited
in Montana some great American Heroes
were on social media promising to shoot
it down themselves unsurprisingly
putting patriotic fervor ahead of basic
physics the York County sheriff's office
in South Carolina gave the appropriate
legal advice on Twitter which we also
adopt here on Lee legal don't try and
shoot it your rifle rounds will not
reach it be responsible what goes up
will come down including your bullets
indeed huh I guess that's one thing that
firing a gun randomly in the air won't
actually solve I guess there's a first
time for everything and on top of that
China has just admitted that there is
another balloon over Latin America now
that doesn't involve U.S law so we won't
be covering it here but you will be able
to keep tabs on it with today's sponsor
morning Brew because that's my favorite
way to catch up with pop culture and the
news in fact they already covered
balloon number one when I wake up
morning Brew is the first thing that I
read I've actually been subscribed to
morning Brew for forever it's one of my
absolute favorite newsletters and I'm
thrilled to tell you why because morning
Brew if you didn't already know is a
free daily newsletter delivered Monday
through Sunday it gets you up to speed
on business finance Tech and law in just
five minutes and it provides a fantastic
quick summary of the most important
issues while being witty irreverent and
informative I often literally laugh out
loud and did I mentioned it's completely
free this week I learned all about
Beyonce making Grammy history the record
us job numbers and the Indian
billionaire who lost 108 billion dollars
overnight it's basically exactly the mix
of news that I'm actually actually
interested in and the stuff that I
didn't even know that I wanted to know
about and it's all written in a
hilarious style morning Brew was one of
the few emails that I actually opened
every single day so Legal Eagles this
one is a complete no-brainer morning
Brew is completely free and just takes
15 seconds to subscribe just click on
the link that's on screen right now or
down in the description to get morning
Brew for free and not only will you get
a newsletter that you'll actually read
you'll actually help out this channel
too so click on the link below to get
morning Brew right away and after you
sign up click on this playlist over here
for more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court